hello and welcome to this video but a
bit later I already have a move on the
board playing ac/dc 1934 okay that's my
birth year did ac/dc even exist in 1974
hmm
it's possible I mean like black back in
black that is from 1980 I think and they
were wrong before that it's possible
that's not totally out of the picture
okay so what is why doing here playing
with f3 likely no p3 is a weird move
I mean I'm on a diagonal already and I'm
really happy that I can get in c5 okay I
don't really want to take on the horn
give him the d4 square but
I wonder if it is an idea to allow him
to take but probably not huh b63 may be
tough to say I'm probably better no
matter what I'd really like to prevent
him from playing after the traitor
Knight to c3 and maybe I'm just over
estimating this point and it wasn't
worth investing time over that I could
have just taken on d4 the whole time
which would have been okay but okay now
white is taking a bit of time yeah this
is an interesting choice it's really an
interesting choice now I have to take oh
wow
people have no love for the bishop pair
it seems now it's dark squares look
awful
my idea was in three now so for the
sounds III and then if night eeks
grap on d4 that that wins material but
is actually is actually good huh do you
need to do it it's it's really messy
right let's do it
Knight takes bishop d4 wins wins
material or gives me an excellent
position okay didn't do that here my
idea was Bishop to f5
then take then win III back I just
wonder if that is a really good good way
to play Knight a5 is good as well let's
do that it's probably stronger actually
yeah they're doing all those hammering
outside hope it's not too distracting
but I don't don't exactly know when they
are finished with with this
yeah they're installing a new gauge to
them to them to the place here
or take it take it is night is strong
with f5 this is a bit more a bit more
dynamic not losing more time it's
probably a moot point as the white
position looks pretty pretty much lost
anyway
two bishops a better and nights I know
if you always find examples but you know
it was to be expected him it was really
difficult to to avoid that I think so
Queen f5 Queen g6 wins
and Night Moves I play Quincy six like
93 I mean Knight moves us to imprecise a
troll and we'll win night or one of the
nights
Quinn is ready to go back to g6e any any
moment okay
yeah I was an opening gone wrong I have
a couple of points that I think probably
can be improved upon d4 I don't like
that already why give black that central
space advantage but okay not it's not a
huge deal maybe but be three years it's
a bit odd because the bishop doesn't do
anything on b2 I just passer and if you
want to play c4 do it immediately like
c4 I would probably play c6 Knight c3
for example there should be six
something like that is a normal way of
playing
I still think like is fine there while
of the nice central pawn wedge and this
doesn't look good but okay it's a
playable game and this is just weakening
a lot and again you don't really have
anything positive to show for it the
bishop is not great there I think I
played it too complicated and what the
engine suggested there is just wrong
just to play this right now would like
to play H for me not with the happy
happy it's not happy anyway it's not a
happy move but it is not even playable
here because III is killing here a g5 by
the engine I was thinking this is great
but F takes isn't that clear g5 is the
killer takes h4 yeah it looks bad it
looks bad
this Queen comes just that's going to be
a bad day for the White King yeah my
Queen b6 wasn't wasn't best yet as I
suspected pretty quickly that wasn't the
best way to play and this is not good
why give up that bishop I don't know now
it is finally on a good diagonal and you
give it out that came so h5h war and now
III is not necessary but the engine
likes it it's one of the top choices
there the main point is that the natural
move Knight takes is answered by Bishop
takes and him the problem is that I'm
threatening the exchange but I'm not
taking that because if he goes here I'm
not grabbing this this is a mistake
now here why it's position I mean the
engine gives black an advantage is just
it's counting the exchange but it's not
super clear because the light the dark
squares are very weak and in a practical
game this is not so easy to play I mean
I would happen he played this position
they don't get me wrong but in
comparison if we now look here I would
have taken like him I would have taken
here of course this is a lot stronger
because now the wide structure is
totally killed Knight f5 ok it's
stronger but I would have taken I guess
maybe and then this Center this is this
is just awful
the king is very weak everything here is
weak and yeah like us a lot better the
engine standard it's winning already he
took with the pawn can I win night at 5
even the best move Bishop g4 yeah but
it's it's it's a lot to huge advantage
going back is also strong yeah but this
is this is an easy way to play just
develop everything with tempo
okay King h8 was stronger yeah okay for
Lube g8 yeah but okay yeah you're up ton
of material yeah with black it's not
really oh my god I got a blunder here
that's funny because Queenie 4 is made
or what yeah okay Queen g6 forces the
more or less the Queen trade and we woke
up funny okay so thanks a lot for
watching bye bye